[Music]
on this Thursday night after their
customers were grounded Airline execs
get grilled let me Begin by apologizing
the demands for accountability and
tougher policies to protect air
passengers
rude awakening oh my God an explosion
rocks St Catharines Ontario the danger
to Residents and firefighters a
registered charity in BC caught up in a
national security investigation the
suspicions about its ties to China's
government and Russia's risky rescue
mission to the International Space
Station their Lifeboat has a serious
enough problem
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us some
Canadian Airline executives are
apologizing for the massive disruptions
thousands of Travelers endured over the
holidays Executives from Air Canada
WestJet and sun wing were summoned by
the federal transport committee to
explain how they handled the whole mess
they admitted they failed to deliver the
level of service Canadians expect but
largely blamed the weather transport
Minister Omar Al gabra says that doesn't
explain why stranded passengers were
given so little information
what is unacceptable to them and to me
is when they are kept in the dark about
what alternative plans are they provided
or left stranded for days on end without
any information that was unacceptable
Travelers are demanding answers and
compensation sun wing Alone says it's
received about 7 000 complaints
Mackenzie gray has our top story tonight
after a disastrous travel season Airline
executives are repenting for leaving
Canadians stressed stranded and stuck
let me Begin by apologizing that we fail
to deliver to the level that we had
expected and I apologize for the
disruption you suffered uh during your
trip on us
um you're absolutely right it's if when
we do things right communication is is
the key thing every single westjetter
feels the weight and anguish of not
being able to meet your travel
expectations
Western Air Canada and sun wing all
blaming a combination of weather
Staffing shortages and Airport issues
for not getting thousands of Canadians
home for the holidays unlike traditional
Airlines we don't have the flexibility
on our Network to adjust our schedule
and shift passenger itineraries that
lack of flexibility LED sun wing to
cancel 67 flights over Christmas a
little bit of relief including Sean and
Dana lapworth's trip to Punta Cana of
course do appointment because we'd hope
to get away from the cold and snow for a
week but didn't happen sun wing didn't
give the lap where it's a reason for the
cancellation and have yet to refund the
six thousand dollars they're owed but
they did promise an extra 125 dollars
the minimum amount they're required to
pay for a canceled flight under the air
passenger protection regulations we now
have a backlog of 33 000 complaints the
opposition believed the lap works are
the lucky ones saying the airline was
able to skirt paying penalties to
passengers and they blame the transport
Minister for LAX rules unfortunately the
air passenger protection regime that
you've created has massive loopholes in
it you could fly a 747 through these
things we are looking at uh as I said
almost every aspect of the regulation to
how we can further enhance it and
strengthen it the airlines uninterested
in strengthening those regulations we do
not believe the priority right now
should be additional penalties on the
only group that has any accountability
and regulations that govern it as for
the lapworths they made the best of
their holiday trading in the beaches of
the Dominican for a hotel stay in snowy
Moose Jaw Saskatchewan but that didn't
stop them from bringing their bathing
suits and we weren't getting on that
plane it's like okay well we got to go
somewhere we've done a lot of swimming
and kind of relaxing down at the pool
the holiday travel nightmares weren't
limited to the air with some trains
between Ottawa and Toronto stuck on the
tracks for nearly 20 hours the
transportation committee is expecting to
hear soon from the head of URL Donna on
how they allowed that to happen
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
it turns out a damaged database file is
to blame for that huge outage yesterday
in the United States that caused
thousands of flight delays and
cancellations the Federal Aviation
Administration says the glitch led to
the failure of the flight safety system
which alerts Pilots to potential hazards
investigators say they are still trying
to pinpoint the cause but repeat it
again there's no sign of a Cyber attack
air traffic operations have resumed but
delays and cancellations are spilling
over into today there has been a large
explosion at a fuel distribution
facility in Quebec and at least one
person is missing flames and black smoke
billowed above the facility in Saint
north of Montreal as a precaution a one
kilometer evacuation Zone was set up
around the site that's now been lifted
police warn though more explosions are
possible because of the propane tanks at
the Fuel Depot an investigation is
underway and search crews are trying to
determine if anyone else is missing
everything we're doing right now is
phone calls and trying to locate some
workers employees of the place just to
make sure where they working today and
and in Ontario a series of loud
explosions startled people in St
Catharines early this morning it
happened at a hazardous waste facility
one man is critically injured and a huge
Blaze lit up the sky as Mike drelaya
reports concerns about air quality means
some people will be unable to return
home tonight
the giant Fireball lit up the morning
sky and the accompanying blast was felt
over two kilometers away oh my God for
the next hour aerosol cans continued to
explode like fireworks
Craig cozen young lives 200 meters away
and says his bedroom lit up in a glow of
orange we were all standing outside and
Embers were all coming down in Ash like
I said and you could hear it crackling
it's not yet known what started the fire
at Sonic's products a chemical disposal
facility one employee in the building
was severely injured as firefighters
arrived on scene the roof collapsed
forcing them to surround the building
and drown the fire with water and while
parts of the structure continued to burn
throughout the day it was contained
even as they continued to fight The
Blaze fire Crews realized they had two
problems they had to deal with number
one they didn't know what chemicals were
inside the building and two a breeze
began pushing potentially hazardous
smoke over a nearby subdivision the
decision was then made to evacuate that
area later in the day evacuees waiting
at an aquatic center were told in no
uncertain terms stay away without
mincing words give your heads a shake
you're not making things better you're
not making things easier or you're not
being helpful you're making things
actively worse please stay out of the
area even with the fire contained
officials were in no hurry to open up
the area because of the ongoing danger
of hazardous chemicals exploding it's
not just one substance there's a whole
bunch so trying to say you know it's one
chemical we can't do that hazardous
materials teams were on site early
ensuring any runoff didn't flow into
Lake Ontario even so residents expressed
concern about lingering impacts from the
incident this is our fear what's down
the road
if things need decontaminated
they don't know they're hoping for some
clarity before they return home micro
light Global News Saint Catharines
Ontario
in Saskatchewan the star blanket
cremation has completed a year-long
ground penetrating radar search at a
former residential school they
discovered what they call 2000 anomalies
that does not mean 2 000 potential Grays
they could be rocks or tree roots though
the First Nation does say one child's
Jawbone was found as Melissa ridgeen
reports much more in-depth work needs to
be done
this information is going to hit home
I'm not going to
not gonna lie that's the message star
blanket search team had for community
members who gathered at the former
residential school gym for a debrief
after phase one of the search for
residential school Graves ground
penetrating radar found 2 000 anomalies
in the area surrounding the school each
one needing further investigation to
separate what is debris left by a
glacier thousands of years ago and which
should be investigated as possible human
remains we'll send a core drill down
collect a sample bring it up and test
that sample for DNA on a an area of
Interest it will be a painstakingly long
process that can't start until spring
funding for phase two of the search will
likely have to come from Ottawa prime
minister Justin Trudeau seems supportive
this work is only just beginning
and of course the federal government
will be there to support you every step
of the way star blanket 80 kilometers
Northeast of Regina is just one
community in the early stages of looking
for children who didn't come home from
residential school The Truth and
Reconciliation Commission told Canadians
back in 2015 there are undocumented and
unmarked Graves at many of the country's
139 residential school sites but for
many Canadians that truth didn't sink in
until May 2021 went to Kamloops equippum
announced what they believed to be 215
Graves outside the Kamloops residential
school in the time since the list of
communities that are searching continues
to grow as they try to find and identify
buried children and either leave them
where they rest or finally bring them
home Melissa ridgeen Global News
Winnipeg
Human Rights Watch has again given
Canada's treatment of indigenous people
a failing grade each year the
organization looks at how human rights
around the world are being violated and
what can be done to strengthen those
rights as Heather urich's West reports
this year's report highlights how the
protection of indigenous women and girls
in this country is falling short
a New Year may bring New Hope but for
many indigenous communities so many
injustices of the past remain here we
are still trying to deal with all of the
enormity of this issue in a beautiful
country like Canada that has such high
standards for human rights but doesn't
have those high standards for human
rights for indigenous people eight years
since the Truth and Reconciliation
commission's calls to action Human
Rights Watch says Canada is still
falling short its annual report found
widespread violations of the rights of
indigenous peoples immigration detainees
people with disabilities and older
people pointing out that 28 First Nation
communities across Canada remain subject
to long-term water advisories and that
81 percent of indigenous women who had
been in the child welfare system have
been physically or sexually assaulted in
their lifetime there's nothing
unfortunately surprising in there
particularly around when you're looking
at the levels of sexual violence that
they're speaking to last spring Canada's
indigenous Services Minister said she
hoped Canada will be able to lift all
remaining drinking water advisories by
2025. the government also released a
national action plan to address murdered
and missing indigenous women and girls
last year but the progress is slow and
it's not saving lives not yet not yet
right because the numbers are still you
know the cases are still happening
Advocates are pushing governments to do
more but the solutions are not political
alone with anti-indigenous racism
present across so many aspects of
Canadian society and until we deal with
systemic racism and we put forward
policies to change systemic racism it's
going to perpetuate until the genocide
is complete education and awareness
might be the most important part of this
puzzle because even in a country like
Canada human rights abuses are more
likely to continue when kept in the dark
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
a special counsel has been appointed to
investigate U.S President Joe Biden's
handling of classified documents found
on his property and in an office the
White House has confirmed a second batch
of classified documents was found after
a search of the library and garage of
the president's Delaware home they date
back to when he was vice president as do
a bachelor files found in an office he
used during the Obama Administration
Biden says he is fully cooperating with
the investigation
a registered charity in Canada under
scrutiny coming up it's alleged ties to
the Chinese government
a BC group with charitable status in
Canada is part of an RCMP investigation
into activities allegedly targeting
members of the Chinese Canadian
Community RCMP national security
officers were seen at the headquarters
of the wenzhou friendship society last
month as part of an investigation into
allegations associated with the Chinese
government's foreign interference
tactics as nithu garcha reports police
in Canada are just starting to untangle
what's alleged to be a State security
apparatus operating out of a handful of
centers
this building in a busy Richmond BC
neighborhood houses the operations of
the Wen Zhao friendship society which
says it supports new immigrants and
helps them give back to Canada what goes
on inside the Gated property is part of
a Canadian National Security
investigation and the subject of a
global news investigation on the rcmp's
probe into allegations China has been
operating covert centers in Canada using
threats intimidation and Corruption to
suppress local opposition and influence
policy the society's website tax returns
and social media Pages indicate it sends
delegates to Gatherings with Chinese
Communist Party officials while taking
part in local fundraising initiatives
the site also includes a message
praising Chinese president XI jinping's
strong leadership it has also been
registered federally as a charity since
2002 receiving federal tax benefits
express our concern Victor ho is a
former journalist with how daily
Canada's largest Chinese Canadian
newspaper it is doing something for the
foreign government obviously this is for
Chinese government how come this happen
and then we have no laws and no
government officials to take note on it
or even Pro ebit or forbidden it the
society isn't facing any criminal
charges a director with the society has
denied any wrongdoing but interview
requests have gone unanswered as have
knocks on the door at the Wen Zhao
friendship society and the society's
website says it has attended meetings
and events with members of the united
front work department and the overseas
Chinese Affairs office two groups the
Canadian government alleges are key
parts of the Chinese Communist Party
strategy to pressure and manipulate its
diaspora members of the RCMP were seen
here at the society's location last
month its integrated national security
info enforcement team said Chinese
Canadians are victims of the activity
they're investigating this is very
ridiculous to me the organization or the
society
receive Canadian taxpayers money there
have been similar police probes in the
Toronto area where the Spanish
non-profit group Safeguard Defenders
identified two so-called overseas police
service stations which appear to support
China's alleged efforts to repatriate
dissidents living abroad
the Wen Zhao friendship society is part
of a 130 member Alliance of Chinese
associations in Canada formed in 2008
and the probe into its operations could
just be the start of Canada's unraveling
of alleged covert Chinese efforts to
advance its strategic interests
nitugarcha Global News Richmond BC
animal activists ahead pressuring the
federal government to keep a promise and
end the export of live horses to Japan
Japan's prime minister is in Ottawa
today meeting Justin Trudeau the economy
and trade was front and center along
with security issues particularly those
in eastern Asia our chief political
correspondent David Aiken was keeping an
eye on the meeting David
well Donna prime minister fumio kashida
is touring G7 capitals ahead of hosting
the G7 Summit in Japan in May and
threats in his part of the world have
been a constant theme on that tour every
G7 member except Japan of course is part
of the North Atlantic and European
Community where Russia's war on Ukraine
has been the most pressing security
threat
's task is to remind his G7 colleagues
including prime minister Justin Trudeau
that an increasingly belligerent China
and North Korea pose serious threats in
East Asia
it is very important kashida told
reporters to have a strong defense
capability in such a severe security
environment which is why Canada welcomes
so strongly the The New National
Security strategy that prime minister
kashida just put forward Japan just
doubled its defense budget and is now
acquiring missiles and other weapons
with offensive capability the first
changes in Japan's defense posture since
the end of the second world war today's
Ukraine could be tomorrow's East Asia
and so there's a real concern that that
China could use unilateral aggression to
change the status quo and that's what
this is about it is purely defensive
though security issues will be top of
mind for the G7 trade was also an
important topic during sheeta's visit to
Canada's capital obviously we talked a
lot about how Canada can be a reliable
supplier not just of energy but of
critical minerals of uh
Commodities and resources including
agricultural resources Trudeau wants to
build on that he announced today he is
going to dispatch a trade mission to
Japan in October Donna and David Canada
continues to export live horses to Japan
where they are killed and eaten the
Trudeau government had promised to end
the export of live live horses for
Slaughter so what's happening
it did Donna during the 2021 election
campaign the Liberals promised to end
the export of live horses to Japan
activists some of whom were on
Parliament Hill today and took these
pictures say the long journey by air to
Japan is stressful and inhumane for the
animals now the Liberals say they are
still working on keeping that promise
the issue did not come up during prime
minister kashida's visit today the
Canadian government says about 50 000
live horses have been exported to Japan
in the last eight years and of those
authorities are aware of the deaths of
just five animals while in transit the
Canadian food inspection agency says it
ensures horses are fit for travel and
are transported humanely Donna all right
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you stranded
in space next Russia's rescue mission to
the International Space Station
[Music]
Russia's space agency is gearing up for
an out of this world mission it intends
to rescue two cosmonauts and an
astronaut from the International Space
Station the soyuz capsule they were
supposed to come home in is damaged so
as Jackson prosco explains they need
someone to come and get them
noticing a stream of particles coming
out of the soyuz like a car with a blown
radiator the soyuz spacecraft has no way
to cool down particles
of what could be uh coolant fluid the
ship lost all of its coolant in December
after a direct hit from a microscopic
micrometeoroid while docked at the
International Space Station
Russia's space agency now says the
capsule is unsafe which is bad news for
the two Russians and one American who
were expecting to ride the soyuz back to
Earth after months in orbit basically
their Lifeboat has a serious enough
problem that they can't trust it to
bring them home former Canadian
astronaut Chris Hadfield flew aboard a
soyuz capsule for his mission commanding
the ISS if your ship has no way to
provide cooling you can rapidly get to
the point where human beings can no
longer function space is a dangerous
place and this situation is now extra
risky because there are actually seven
people on board the space station from
two different Crews suddenly there's no
option for everyone to escape in an
emergency the station's only other
Lifeboat seats just four
in February Russia plans to launch an
empty soyuz to bring the men back which
will delay the launch of the next ISS
replacement crew by months three will
come home the other four will get some
unexpected extra time to enjoy the view
and all things considered they're likely
not complaining oh it's it's uh it's
like a gift all it does is give those
three people a greater chance to do what
they've trained their whole lives for
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is a little far out NASA's
James Webb Telescope has confirmed the
existence of an exoplanet that's a
planet that orbits another star it's
about 41 light years away and it's
almost the same size as Earth thanks for
watching Fara Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I will see you
Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]